What is up with this idea of people being left-brained and right-brained?
Is it myth? Actually, no.
The thing is some people are more left-brained and others
are more right-brained. We found
out what determines which side has dominance
happens before even born. In the womb,
when our xxx develops, the way they wire up to our developing brain determines which side is dominant.
Why do we have dominant side?
Lateralization.
This refers to some brain functions taking place in one hemisphere
or one side rather than the other.
Each hemisphere controls a different body side as well.
Your dominant brain side connects to your dominant body side.
The left side of the brain controls the right side of the body.
And the right side the left.
This cross-wiring neural pathway means
if you are left-handed you are more relying on the right side of the brain.
And again vice versa.
How does this affect our think style?
The left side and the right are responable for very distinct thinking patterns.
Generally, the right brain thinks in pictures
instead of words.
Using intuition and focusing on the bigger picture.
The left focuses on actual words.
Thinking in a very verbal way. Holding into details first,
and then putting them toghter to form a whole picture.
It's why we agree upon that the right side is creative
and the left is logical.
How is language afftected?
The left side is good for vocabulary, grammar, and literal meanings.
The right side is great for intonation and accentuation,
basically, how we speak.
How is music heard in the brain?
We alreay know the right side is more creative.
Music processing takes place in the entire brain.
With the right side focusing on the melody while the left side focuses on
the motor scale your hands need to play the instrument.
It's true that math is left brain business.
We assume the left side being more logical does more math.
Things such as adding, counting, subtracting, etc.
The right, however, actually helps us with estimating amount of set of objects.
While your left brain might help you take a test,
the right brain can tell you how many boxex are still on the dilevery pallet at work.
Which side handles the memories?
The hippocampus is actully the part of the brain associated with memory.
And it occupies both sides of the brain.
The left side has been deemed more important for storing memories,
as its strength is in retrieval.
The right side is good for reciting, like multiplication tables.
Which side will help me more in wieding in survival camp?
Depending on our situation,
the sides we depend on change.
Studies have shown that, in a warm places with more xxx moods
and less risks to your life, the right side is better.
The left kicks in when it's cold.
The food is xxx and threads to your life like a wielding polar bear are abondant.
Survival skills are
based more on spatial awarance and logic.
Not creativity.
So the left side controls more of our ability to survive.
How does damage xx the right side affect person?
Damage xx the right side
and even suicide.
An over-acted right side can cause feelings of depression and inksed.
It can also case problems with language and preception.
So just the lacks of motion while speaking.
How does damage to the left side affect a person?
Left side damage affects vision.
There is a reduction in spatial frequency. So we only see the larger part of a image.
Speech also seems to be litered with gramatical errors.
This is called
So, which side is superior?
It is important to stress that there is
no right or wrong way to think.
Both sides have their advantages and simply represents two ways of thinking.
If you want to increase your brain power,
work on both sides if your are XX.